here
i um
posted a
com or a
post
on my blog the linguist on language and
i'll try to remember to leave a link
here
where i talked about uh
you know uh
whether we can learn a hundred words a
day
and i think that since i started check i
have learned more than 100 words a day
maybe 150 words a day i don't know
uh i describe all these numbers on my
blog post
basically link says that i know 200 or
25 000 words
um that includes
non-words numbers names how many of
those there are i don't know maybe 10
um plus i have saved about 20 000 links
which includes
a number of phrases
of the words that i have saved i don't
know how many i know but i think i know
maybe a third of them
so
you know 25 28 000 words in there that
so then i i said that and then someone
uh you'll see this all on the exchange
on my blog
various people challenged different
aspects of this
uh stefan
from denmark
uh
you know said well yeah but that's
true in an inflected language like
like um
check where
you know
a noun might have six or seven different
forms
uh verbs have different forms in english
there are fewer forms i mean we do have
i go but we have he goes
and you go and ego and went and the gone
so we have a few forms
of the verb probably verbs we have as
many forms as the czechs have but in
nouns we just have the singular and the
plural and the checks might have six or
seven so if i have theoretically 25 28
000 words in check
what is that equivalent to in
english
i know that um
professor nation nation in new zealand
has said that the relationship between
words and word families is one to 1.6 in
english
we also know from research we did at
link
that
those lessons like who is she and so
forth which are
common to all of our languages or our
supported languages
that there are more unique words
in say russian or french than there are
in english and that ratio is 2 to 1 for
russian or 1.5 to 1 for the romance
languages
so we get some of a sense that therefore
you know if my target in terms of
learning words
the way we count them at link which is
each different form of the word is
different so goals is different from
goal
that on that basis if we say you need 10
000 words
for a certain level
in english you you will need 15 000
in french and you'll need 20 000 in
korean or russian let's say
so these numbers are all you know
to be taken with a grain of salt but but
they're there because they're an
indication of of progress
so
and i know that with my 25 28 000 words
in check after six months that i can
read the newspaper on a subject that's
familiar to me
uh so i do know quite a lot of words
so then the next uh point of attack or
or challenging this whole thing
uh came from a person who said well
you know as a language learner he said
i think you can only say that you know a
word if you know how to use it at will
so this is this whole discussion of
passive vocabulary versus active
vocabulary and i said that i consider
that i know a word if i can recognize it
in a certain context
very often i can recognize the word in a
context but if outside the context i may
not know the meaning of the word but to
me that is enough so this was the major
point of disagreement between me and
this person neil who you know with with
a lot of good goodwill and so forth said
look i'm struggling to learn cantonese
that's the language that he's learning
and um
you know i can't learn 100 words a day
there's no way
and to me i when i consider a word known
is when i can actually use it at will he
said
well i want to challenge the idea that
you only know a word when you can use it
and particularly use it at will and i
and i do this for a number of reasons
first of all
when i go to learn a language my first
goal
is to understand it my first goal is
comprehension i want to be able to read
and understand i want to be able to
listen
and understand listen to audio books
listen to people talking watch movies so
number one goal is to understand in
order to understand i only need to know
the meaning of words in specific
contexts in other words helped by the
surrounding words so that i can figure
out the meaning i know it well enough to
understand it when i see it or hear it
that's my number one goal
now
that's point number one point number two
even in my own language i know far more
words passively than i use actively
and if that's ratio is three to one i
don't know
but in a foreign language the ratio is
much larger always even in languages
that i speak well
because
i'm not as confident
in a foreign language
uh i for sure want to understand what
the other person is saying but when i go
to speak i rely on the words that i that
i really know
that are trusty words that i know
exactly what they mean i know that
they're correct in this context i know
that these words are used with these
other words in this way in this context
i use only the words that i can really
trust
words that you know i might try i might
experiment with the odd word to see if
it doesn't raise any strange you know
expressions on the face of native
speakers but mostly i rely on the tried
and true
words and expressions that i know work
and i'm much more conservative in using
words than when i'm trying to understand
what people are saying and this is
perfectly normal
so i think it's perfectly normal that
your
passive vocabulary in a foreign language
might be 10 times your active vocabulary
and
if say i'm learning russian and one of
my goals in learning russian is to read
tolstoy so i want to understand tolstoy
but i cannot presume to use words like
tolstoy that's just not going to happen
he has at his disposal because he is an
artist he is he creates using words
that's his medium and i'm going to use
all the words that he uses i don't think
so i want to understand the words that
he uses and that's perfectly legitimate
so suggest to suggest that you're going
to use all the words that you can learn
passively to me is not realistic
furthermore it's not realistic to think
i think it's counterproductive to say
that if you come across a word you're
going to try and nail that word down
until you can use it at will until you
can use it anywhere and so forth that's
not realistic it's far more realistic
to let your passive vocabulary grow
through lots of reading and listening
lots of exposure lots of enjoyment of
the language
understanding what people are saying in
conversation
and not worrying about when those words
convert into words that you can use they
will do so
gradually if you try to nail down every
single word that you learn and convert
it into something that you can use that
will will
of course your vocabulary will grow very
slowly because it's a very difficult
thing to do it's not because you're
studying this list of words it's not
because you're going through flashcards
that those words are going to stick for
you
in fact very often things that we study
now
won't stick for us until six months
later so it's better to forget about it
you learned it
you forgot it you learned it you forgot
it you kind of can figure out what it
means in a context when you read you
can't yet figure out what it means when
you hear it
doesn't matter you just keep going you
expose yourself to more content
gradually and surprisingly quickly your
passive vocabulary grows and it grows
largely incidentally in other words most
of the words that i know and check i did
not deliberately study on my flashcards
most of the words that i know and check
or russian or french are words that i
just
got to know because i've been reading so
much and they kept on showing up and
they're similar to other words and and i
was able to infer the meaning and all of
a sudden they're part of my vocabulary
but my passive vocabulary and over a
further period of time as i'm speaking
more and searching for words and
occasionally i'll reach back in there
for one of those passive words bring it
out use it and it worked you know my
native speaker friend didn't say that
what do you i don't understand he seemed
to understand and so slowly these
passive words are converted into active
words but in my opinion when we evaluate
how many words we can learn
and how many words we know it's it's as
passive words and i sat down to dinner
with my wife who is not a keen language
learner but she speaks a few languages
but she's not into this discussion at
all i just said to you
you know when i when i ask you if you
know a word in a foreign language does
it mean that you can use it or does it
mean that you can understand it and she
said that i can understand it so that's
my take on it
be happy if you have
passive vocabulary focus on the passive
vocabulary increase your comprehension
your ability to understand what you read
and what you hear and the active
vocabulary will come don't get hung up
this is my advice this is how i learn
you can do it however you want but don't
get hung up on the idea that you have to
use or be able to use all the words you
learn because that's very very difficult
to do so that's my answer to my friend
neil murray who's been commenting uh on
my blog
and that's my take on this whole issue
of how quickly can we learn words and
what do we mean when we say we know a
word thank you and i look forward to
your comments